do you want to learn about orgasms
yes
yes boy do i ever i thought you'd never
ask me too so uh
i looked at a study accounting for
women's orgasms and sexual enjoyment in
college hookups and relationships so
this looked at investigated the
determinants of orgasm and sexual
enjoyment in hookup and relationship sex
among heterosexual college women and
seeks to explain why relationships sex
is better for women in terms of orgasm
and sexual enjoyment we found that women
have orgasms more often in relationships
than in hookups regression analysis
reveal that specific sexual practices
experience with a particular partner and
commitment all predict women's orgasm
and sexual enjoyment the presence of
more sexual practice conducive to
women's orgasm in relationship sex
explains some of why orgasm is more
common in relationships
there is also a double standard
contributing to why relationship sex is
better for women both men and women
question women's but not men's
entitlement to pleasure in hookups
but believes strongly in women's as well
as men's entitlement to pleasure in
relationship more attention is thus
given to producing female orgasm in
relationships but not in hookups and
here's the stats so
if you've had no prior hookups with this
partner 11 orgasm one or two prior
hookups with this partner 16 orgasm
three plus prior hookups
and six plus months of a relationship 67
yeah and um i i almost know the reason
why it's like
when you are first getting into some
sort of relationship whether it be
physical
whether you have the intention of going
further there is the
you have to kind of hide your cards you
you have to
as a guy
both women and men
and the discussion around sex is still a
mystery it's like you kind of have this
thing where if you're gonna hook up with
someone
you're like oh man i still have to like
make this move at this time and i can't
just outwardly say okay so now we're
gonna have sex now can you tell me
exactly what pleasures you and can you
you know what i mean like that's that's
not the the level of discussion but as
you get into relationship you're damn
near [__] in front of your
girlfriend
right and your girlfriend is you know
doing everything like you guys there's
no filter so at that point she could be
like hey you know do this exact thing
and we're both going to have a party in
here it's going to be great yeah that to
me that seems like the only logical
reason yeah so it said the um
the presence of more sexual practice
conducive
uh experience with a particular partner
and commitment as well was another one
so i wanted to dig into this more so i
read that yeah like this is pretty
interesting so i want to find out what
causes women to enjoy
sex more uh again from this very
rigorous bro science study that i've
been doing and what got me onto it was i
was chatting to a bisexual girl actually
who's just come out of a relationship
with her first relationship with a girl
and she said to me
making a girl orgasm feels like quite an
achievement i can see why men enjoy it
but what that highlighted was that for
girls making a man come is just like
well it's it's gonna happen like if i
just keep pumping away
yep it's gonna happen just keep pumping
you know
and and then it it happens in the end
whereas with a girl there's more
intricacies going on right
so this is [__] fascinating man the
influence of types of stimulation and
attitudes to clitoral self-stimulation
on female sexual and orgasms
satisfaction a cross-sectional study so
long and short of it
is
long and short of it is that girls on
the whole
see any type of orgasm that involves
using the clitoris as a second standard
it's like a second class quality
for it okay which is pretty crazy so
whether women experience orgasms depends
mainly on the type of sexual activity
direct stimulation of the clitoris
improves the regularity of experienced
orgasms called orgasm consistency and
orgasm quality
during sexual intercourse without direct
clitoral stimulation only about
one-third of females experience an
orgasm in contrast during masturbation
59 of women usually experience an orgasm
blah blah blah blah blah forward and
back forward and back women who orgasm
more frequently reported a higher
awareness of their bodily sensations
more erotic fantasies during intercourse
more variation in their sexual behavior
and higher emotional intimacy so
emotional intimacy comes back to the
relationship thing again yeah many women
yeah go ahead sorry many women who have
difficulties experiencing an orgasm
report psychological strain and low
satisfaction with their sexual
relationship a low orgasm frequency is
related to cognitive distraction eye
automatic thoughts suppression of erotic
thoughts pressure to perform and sexual
myths so
overall here it says that
orgasm consistency through sexual
intercourse had a stronger influence on
orgasm satisfaction and sexual
satisfaction than orgasm consistency
through oral sex stimulation by the
partner's hand or self-stimulation this
is surprising since many women even
describe an orgasm as more pleasurable
when stimulated directly by the clitoris
and female orgasms least likely to be
caused by this type of stimulation
although there is no biological
difference between a vaginal and a
clitoral orgasm many women seem to
desire orgasms through purely vaginal
penetration the results indicate that
the common misconception about sexuality
that it is normal for women to
experience orgasms during penile vaginal
intercourse
influences the subjective evaluation of
one's own sexuality orgasms from
clitoral stimulation seem to have a
second class quality for some women
while there is no evidence that these
orgasms feel less pleasurable
because
it would seem as though the clitoral
stimulation is almost like a hack
right it's like you get your vibrator
you go right for it
you have the images in your brain or you
watch porn it just you get it done
and if they can
kind of teleport themselves to wherever
they need to be while sex is happening
and they get clitoral stimulation they
can almost do exactly the same thing
that they were doing you know during
masturbation uh
but
the purely
would is it vaginal yeah purely vaginal
um one would mean that their connection
with
whomever it is that they're hooking up
with was so strong that it didn't
require that you can't whack your way
out of it yeah and i think that yeah
what was really [__] interesting was
the talk about cognitive distraction
automatic thoughts suppression of erotic
thoughts pressure to perform and sexual
myths so the biggest
restriction
to girls
coming during sex
purely through penetrative sex
is their own mind
yes yes and
part of it is the you know all of the
things you listed above it's kind of the
trickle-down effect there's
the it's vulnerability at the end of the
day right i mean it's
why would i open myself up completely
carnally like everything to this person
if they're going to leave me
right it's it's like that's almost what
it requires
to have that level of an orgasm and for
women who like
and again this is
i'm speaking of someone who's like sure
of themselves right but i'm a [__]
bro and like like trust me i'm aware
um but i'm i'm working through this
because this is very interesting you
know and it also takes
it takes experience on both ends like
i've had my ex experience and
frustrations and successes
um
but what i
what i can ultimately say is like
that i i wonder
where masturbation for women plays into
all of this because i know for a fact
that masturbation on the men's side what
with using with the use of porn um and
like your own hand
that can affect your sexual stimulation
and there's been actually a lot there's
this huge meta analysis um that i want
to show you i i didn't don't i obviously
was not prepared for this discussion
uh but there's a huge meta-analysis
talking about
um porn and its effects on
male stimulation
uh you know in order to like the
inability to have an erection sustain an
erection expectation and then how it
affects the relationship
so it can cause relationship breakups it
can cause divorce it can be a catalyst
to cause breakups it can be a catalyst
to cause divorce and i wonder
the female side of that
right because i when i end up trying to
get uh close with a female i actually
ask them these things
about masturbation about these things
because it's like one i'm curious and
two it's like i
i can't judge i'm not going to judge you
you know what i mean it's not we are we
live in a different time where
you know back in the 50s 60s 70s like no
one talks about masturbation no one
talks about sex i want you to get there
i want to know about how asking a girl
her masturbation technique intricacies
how it comes about on a first date i
want to know how that goes yeah not on
the phone how many days how many dates
do you need to go
look i've gotten it on the first date to
talk about it you know because it's like
i'm open about whatever it's it's hard
for them you know
i don't want to make the person
uncomfortable so the conversation is the
first place i go to masturbation yeah no
no the conversation i go to is following
their lead
right i'm not going to push any further
because there's nothing i hate more than
like making the person sitting across me
feel awkward and
that you have to build that trust
overcome conversation obviously
and more likely than not on a first date
you're going to end up talking about
relationships are you not
what you know because you want to know
about the person who you know who have
you dated what was wrong with it what
was what did you do wrong what did they
do wrong what do you like what don't you
like and it if you're not talking about
sex at that point
right at some point you have to start
talking about sex if you talk about sex
you talk about
people not being good at sex or you talk
about people being good at sex what they
did that was good and then
masturbation habits end up having to be
discussed
right i just kind of bro science walked
you through exactly how that's why
that's why you're doing it okay so
i think bro science time i think that
the pressure to perform and the sexual
myths which are two of the four reasons
for low orgasm frequency according to
this study pressure to perform comes
from um
what they predict the partner expects
from them and because of how much porn
is around i think that that probably
will have made girls believe that they
need to
act in a certain way i have seen some
studies saying that um more men and
women believe that anal sex should
happen because it like just happens in
porn so therefore it porn is a
representation of intimacy that happens
in the normal world and then the sexual
myths thing is about the fact that in
most porn it looks like girls do orgasm
through sex
so
the girl themselves feels oh well this
myth is part of me now i don't know how
much of a myth thing it is because when
it's self-created
through
the girls on rumination and automatic
thoughts and suppression and blah blah
blah
that's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
that's like your the thing that you want
to have happen you're stopping it from
happening because of how badly you want
it to happen
it's pretty
uncomfortable situation that's i mean
that's essentially right like what's the
one thing that men face is ability to
get it up yup you know and then the
thought process of trying to get it up
makes it worse
don't think about it babe don't think
about it it'll just happen okay you
don't want me to think about it now now
all i can do is think about it yeah
right so it's kind of the same thing if
a woman wants to have an orgasm and you
and like
you know that's all they're thinking
about and then they think oh crap well
i'm not it's not i'm doing it right is
it happening right is he enjoying it am
i enjoying it should i be doing this
yes yes that's such a good analogy
yeah and i mean
i i saw i think it was someone on rogan
a while back
but this guy was saying you know there's
a mixture of drugs you can take to where
you just let go of everything and it's
uh it's like a
i think it's it would it be called
oxytocin i know that oxytocin is what's
released i know that but is there like a
form of that
something like was this for women or for
guys this was
someone on rogan's podcast was like yo
i've got this combination and you gotta
try it and it was like facebook
something and ketamine
like it's a very my yes for sex a very
mild dose of ketamine in a very mild
dose of like oxytocin or something like
that
oh and then yeah he was also saying you
can rub something directly on your dick
this sounds like ben greenfield this
sounds like very very ben greenfield
okay it could it could have honestly
been him i i don't remember but i
remember the comments being like yo this
guy is [__]
insane for suggesting for suggesting
people going out of their way to get
some ketamine from like some random
[__] you know by the way all of
these drugs are illegal you know but
drugs are well discussed on rogan um but
i
i it's one of those things take yourself
out of your brain and be present it's
very there's a limit though there's a
limit to taking yourself out of your
brain like if i if i have enough
ketamine i'm not on the same planet
anymore
i'm trying to get out into the astral
plane right you know that's where i am
i'm trying to get out and look be above
the bed while we're [__] i wanna
you know
like in like in that movie with um
you just get shoved into the astral
plane
i'm just saying
benedict cumberbatch was trying to get
all of his skills so that he could have
sex in the astral plane yes exactly yes
i'm glad we're in agreement what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace